there of course like a ton of different
college rankings and the forbes list i
think really kind of makes it stand out
is it's all about outcomes so a lot of
college lists other ones look at
relative selectivity how hard it is to
get into a school a lot of kind of soft
metrics based on like relative prestige
and the forbes list what's different is
we look at it like outputs we look at it
like an investment you know for most
people in their lives it's one of the
biggest things i'll ever spend money on
the list is kind of about finding what
are the safest investments and kind of
keep tweaking the methodology originally
we did look at some of those kind of
like student experience measures like
how do students like their schools you
know what are those kind of retention
rates and we have some of that that
stayed around
but for the most part we're looking at
kind of hard outcome measures so what's
the kind of debt people are leaving with
what kind of salaries are alumni earning
after the fact what kinds of
you know companies are they starting are
they earning phds are they earning uh
any kind of like prestigious national
award we're looking at how quickly are
people able to pay off those loans i
would say the biggest thing we did this
year was that we really tried to account
for how schools
are
treating their low-income students to do
that we looked at a lot of data on pell
grants which is kind of like a
way that the federal government helps
make families with lower middle income
able to afford college and we
looked at how schools are graduating
long-term students what kind of salaries
they have after the fact and how quickly
they can pay off all the total costs of
college after you take out scholarships
and everything
and that's new to our methodology so the
number one this year was really exciting
it's uc berkeley you know i mean for
past i think three years straight and
then just kind of every you know every
other year going back further than that
the list has been dominated by harvard
at large and then kind of the ivies but
this year a public school came out
number one and it was pretty cool i mean
berkeley obviously is like
the crown jewel of the university
california system incredibly elite
school but i think what really really
made it stood out for us was what's
happening to low income students low and
moderate income students who go to
berkeley because
obviously when you get to this top of
the rankings these are all really really
fine distinctions but the cool thing
institutionally about berkeley is that
not only do its low-income graduates do
really well but they also take on a lot
of low-income students a school like
harvard across the board their
undergraduates about 12 are receiving
pell grants those special grants for low
and moderate income families
at berkeley it's 27
and for the whole average of the top 600
it's around 25 so they really really
kind of stood head and shoulders there
um
other things we do look at like
we'll look at alumni of forbes lists so
things like the 30 under 30 the forbes
400 the most powerful women self-made
women and berkeley does really really
well there yale was number two princeton
number three and they're always near the
top of the list and they do really good
stuff i mean yale i think really
commendably did really really great work
for like graduating those pell grant
recipient students they produce a ton of
really accomplished alumni
same thing with princeton cool with
princeton
by far and away the lowest debt that of
those top schools
lowest debts coming out of princeton
they also have like a really really high
success rate of producing phds people
who win academic prizes so just really
impressive stuff there and then stanford
where stanford is you know it's number
four there but it is kind of by far and
away number one when it comes to alumni
pay so alumni if you went to stanford
you're probably you know in for
something good in terms of money they do
really well with alumni and forbes lists
and that's a lot of people kind of those
connections to silicon valley and tech
they go on to start you know these
really interesting startups and
you know we take note of those and they
end up on our list and that's
another area where stanford shines
uh colombia all around just like really
really solid as well maybe the thing
that kept it out of this top four
they're a bit weaker on some of those
dead measures but just incredibly strong
performer as well all around the
university of california system in
general did really really well i mean
they had four schools in the top 25 so
that was
davis santa barbara and ucla and they
all just perform really well the system
does a lot of good for
its graduates and just kind of
consistently across the board
does a lot for those low income
graduates you know these lists are
really exciting when it comes to
thinking about just you know the
four-year residential college experience
kind of like the
golden ideal of you know going off to
college which is just something that
doesn't necessarily reflect how
honestly a majority of college students
experience higher education you know
people are
not necessarily living in residential
schools they're not there for just clean
four years
and i think that's really what we're
trying to start capturing with this list
is what is the actual
what does higher education in the us
actually look like right now and
you know there's no way that any ranking
is going to get that but i think we're
getting at it a lot better than we used
you